okay the reason I'm talking about this
every day and Pat's getting frustrated
with it but we're gonna persevere is
that we are dangerously close to hitting
the number of patrons that we need in
order to finalize production and release
the 12 to 15 part critical thinking
miniseries the background on this is
that we tied the production of a
fantastic miniseries on critical
thinking and argumentation and logical
fallacies to hitting 2,100 patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show this
is a platform that if you visit the
website patreon.com slash david pakman
show you will very easily and clearly
see that merely by hitting the orange
button that says become a patron you can
add to the 2057 patrons that we
currently have and the reason that the
number 2057 is so big is that when we
reach 2,100 patrons which is now only 43
patrons away we will record edit and
upload the multi-part critical thinking
miniseries early last week we had about
a hundred patrons to go late last week
we needed only 85 yesterday I told you
that we needed 57 and today I can tell
you with peace and love that we need
only 43 more patrons in order to hit
that goal we've already been working
I've previewed to you one of the pieces
of the multi-part mini series I've also
shown you and I'm doing it again that we
have a really great animated
introduction custom done by producer
Noah Ferguson for each of the parts of
this critical thinking miniseries it is
going to be really good but I'm both
titillated and concerned because
February first is coming up and
unfortunately what happens on the first
of every month is that when patreon goes
to run everybody's pledges some people's
credit cards and debit cards have
expired since the January pledge and so
that number which is currently 2057 will
get knocked down
sadly it'll probably get knocked down
too
mm yeah I think we need to do like a
telethon maybe you can live stream
I might have to I'll provide the
entertainment a lancia phone calls but
ever got to do whatever we have to do
because that I am worried I think it's
really important that we do this by by
the end of January 31st so if you've got
even a single dollar to pledge please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
we've got we really just need 22 people
today in 21 people tomorrow or 21 today
and 22 tomorrow or 42 today and one
tomorrow divided up however it makes
sense to you 43 pledges and we will be
there and it's gonna be glorious yeah
it's one of the best things that the
david pakman show has ever produced
that's right and that's mostly because I
had pretty much nothing to do with it
right exactly yeah exclusively I would
say now I'm actually I I think it's
going to be it's just so different we've
never really done anything like it
before Pat seems shell-shocked over
there by what's going on but in any case
it's gonna be great that that's what I
can tell you let's do it and don't make
me call Pat's entire family and get them
to make pledges